What's up, Marvel fans?
We're here with Willem Dafoe,
who plays Green Goblin.
All right.
What was your
reaction when you were
told the premise of this film?
It sounded good,
good enough to sign on,
you know, to revisit
this character.
Now what was it like
revisiting that character?
How was that?
It was great.
I mean, it's-- yeah,
it's a continuation.
And this is probably
the most ambitious
film in the series so far.
So it was great to be a part
of it, see some old friends,
see some new friends, you know.
That's incredible.
What was it like working
with Director Jon
Watts and the awesome ensemble?
He was great.
I mean, you know, they had--
a lot of the people had
worked together before.
So they were really--
had good chemistry
already, had a lot of trust.
And yeah, it was-- it was fun
to work, you know, very loose.
But also, you know, we were--
we were making our days
and having fun.
Do you have a favorite
Spider-Man moment in the MCU?
Oh, god.
That-- that's a tough one.
Yeah, too hard.
I get it.
There's so many.
Yeah, no, you know, I
enjoy doing the action stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]